star wars squadrons is available on
october 2 for pc
ps4 and xbox one this review in progress
will assess the game's single player
story campaign and general game
mechanics
over the coming days i'll be testing the
main multiplayer component of the game
which i was unable to access before
launch
and see how the game runs in the wild
before finalizing my thoughts
for all the ups and downs i've had with
various star wars media products over
the past few decades
the formative space combat simulations
of x-wing and tie fighter and ms-dos
or at least my memory of them have
always been a fixed highlight
it's hard to go astray when you're
focused on the minutia of inherently
cool sci-fi fantasy planes
as opposed to whatever's going on with
jedi lineages or space politics now
there have been a few arcade-style star
wars space combat games that filled the
20-year period since the last flight
simulator
and some of them were even good but star
wars squadrons is now making a welcome
return to some of the simulator
intricacies while still retaining a
large degree of the approachable
spectacle of the arcade-style flight
games
and based on the single-player story
campaign the balance squadrons has
settled on works very well
and creates an experience that makes you
feel as if you're really an active
participant in a star wars
but the empire knows we're up to
something now
they'll be looking for us which means
we have work to do
the basic mechanics will be familiar if
you've ever played any kind of flight
game
you pitch a fighter up and down you bank
it left and right you fly forward
not backward and you can twirl until you
feel sick you maneuver your crosshairs
onto an enemy and you fire lasers or
missiles at them
you're locked to a first person cockpit
view of the action but all the
squadron's missions are in space
which means maintaining altitude isn't
something you have to worry about and
instead you get the wonderful freedom of
being able to fly along any axis
and rolling your ship and flying upside
down is a hoot it feels like you could
feasibly finish the squadron's campaign
relying mostly on those principles if
you wanted to
especially on lower difficulties and
that's great but squadrons digs a little
deeper with the ability to reroute power
on your ship
a system that brings a nice layer of
complexity in the advantages that it can
open up for you and the considerations
that come with that each starfighter in
squadrons has the ability to rebalance
their feet of power to prioritize
different ship components the engines
the laser weapons and on certain ships
the shield system
doing so gives you access to specific
benefits related to that system as a
cost of reducing the efficiency of the
others
diverting all the power to the engines
makes your ship more maneuverable gives
you a faster top speed and charges a
speed boost
prioritizing lasers will let you fire
them for longer and focusing on shields
will
allow them to recharge faster and even
overcharge them to absorb more damage
than normal
furthermore ships with shields can also
choose whether to divert shield coverage
to the front of the ship
the back of the ship or balance them all
over it's not exactly on par with the
star wars simulators from the 90s the
power diversion isn't as granular and
you can't adjust your firing patterns or
anything like that but the notable
systems are there
and there's still plenty to think about
when you're in the thick of things you
can leave the systems equally balanced
and still be fine
but it's exciting to make these snap
decisions in the middle of a mission and
act more like the ace pilot you're
supposed to be
sure you could simply let your x-wing
cruise over the star destroyer and shoot
at its targeting module until your
lasers run out eating a bit of damage in
the process and then just
repeat it but you could definitely get
things done way more efficiently if you
shift power to your shields as you
approach in order to overcharge them
flip everything to your lasers as you
begin to fire to get a dozen more shots
in before you overheat
and then push everything to the engines
as you crank the throttle to get clear
quickly shifting all your shields to the
rear
to absorb all the turret fire coming
your way constantly having your mind
occupied with these mechanics on top of
your mission objectives can give even
the most straightforward sorties and
involved and exciting edge to them
especially knowing that you could be
putting yourself at greater risk if
you're in a bad configuration for the
situation
the commands are simple to execute then
mount to the d-pad on a controller by
default
though you can reconfigure all the
controls meaning the challenge comes
from internalizing the best options for
the situations you find yourself in
and remembering to change things up when
the time comes in the heat of the moment
it's these additional complexities and
the advantages they give you that make
me incredibly excited to see how they'll
change the familiar dynamic of video
game dogfighting
in the squadron's multiplayer component
i want to know how high that skill
ceiling goes
of course the feedback you get in
playing with these systems does a lot to
make the experience really satisfying
and the tried and true star wars
production design is executed well in
squadrons
the familiar sounds of droids and proton
torpedoes are weirdly comforting
and hearing the crunch of titanium as
you fly past a tie you just obliterated
is very exciting
the unique cockpits of each ship have a
great look too with easy to read gauges
that don't betray the excellent retro
futuristic boxiness of the ships
themselves
i personally appreciated the extra touch
of 70s chic with some fantastic
hairstyles on some of the pilots
though a few of the cooler campaign
characters obviously didn't get the memo
across 14 missions lasting around 8
hours in total
the campaign of squadrons jumps back and
forth between the journeys of two pilots
each flying on one of the two sides of
the intergalactic war between the
freshly rebranded new republic and the
galactic empire
it all starts with a defection which
leads to a secret military project and
light musings on loyalty
personal morality and what constitutes a
victory while serving during wartime
it's a plot that succeeds in justifying
the escalation of exciting space combat
encounters if nothing else
the missions themselves are all
straightforward in nature all offering a
smattering of dogfighting as well as at
least one other objective such as taking
down a larger enemy ship
defending one of your own or hitting
stationary targets like reactor cores
and shield generators
there is some wiggle room for variants
and approaches or strategies but nothing
major
optional objectives crop up at times
that can serve as ways to make an
upcoming task
easier if you're good enough to complete
them later missions allow you to alter
your loadout and some even let you
choose the ship you take into battle but
for the most part a lot of these
variables are predetermined in such a
way that gives you ample opportunity to
get familiar with the game's meaningful
variety of vehicles and loadout options
what makes these missions special are
not the raw objectives though
it's the spectacle of some of the maps
they take place on squadrons takes you
to some exciting regions of the star
wars galaxy which are easy to appreciate
right away
colorful nebulas filled with lightning
storms star destroyer graveyards and a
shattered moon are just some of the
memorable stages for the campaigning
cannons
you don't need to be a star wars fan to
understand the game's events
there are a couple of brief but notable
cameos from the star wars canon
but more time is spent getting to know
the original characters the members of
vanguard and titan squadrons which are
the republican imperial teams
respectively
they fill their missions with practical
radio chatter but you get a better
opportunity to dive into their
characters
through optional conversations that you
can access before and after missions
vanguard squadron is made up of a ragtag
group of humans and humanoid aliens with
personalities as varying as their colour
palette
the confident one the timid one the
scoundrel
titan squadron on the other hand is an
all-human squad and while each character
shares a hint of backstory that explores
how any sane person in this universe
would come to join the fascist empire
all of that is betrayed by character
designs that strongly suggest that these
people are absolutely
definitely evil you got menacing scars
elitist personalities
an ex-cop who loves delivering justice
and one guy who cannot take off his
terrifying
half-melted full face pilot helmet
get up fight again
all for the empire needless to say
despite the welcome opportunities for
character interaction
the limited amount of face-to-face time
you get to actually spend with your
squads means you're looking to their
lore and personalities rarely goes
too deep and it's hard to form any real
connection with them
compounding this is the fact that your
two protagonists are both silent
despite character customization being
the first thing you're asked to do
part of which is choosing their voice
and personality your character is never
seen and really heard from during the
campaign
you can be an absolute hero who carries
the squad when you're in combat but when
you're simply hanging out in the
hangar you feel more like a fly on the
wall than a member of the squad which is
a bit awkward
conversations with your fellow squad
members are more like lengthy monologues
that you listen to politely
and toward the tail end of the campaign
you feel like a meaningless pawn being
pushed around to fight a few that you
have no feelings on
your character is unable to express even
a fraction of the hesitation or emotion
seen in the supporting cast
which undersells big story beats and
what little the game is trying to
accomplish in its thematic explorations
especially on the empire side but by and
large the majority of the campaign is
still filled with good scenarios that
push you to pilot your funky space
planes as best you can
of course another major component if not
the main component of squadrons
is its 5v5 online multiplayer which
features a dogfighting mode as well as
fleet battles an objective based
tug-of-war scenario between two teams
there's also a progression system that
rewards a variety of cosmetic items and
is notably free from microtransactions
how enjoyable these modes will be over a
long period of time
and how rewarding the game's progression
ladder ends up feeling
is something i'll be trying to come to
terms with over the following days
but as my experience stands right now
the campaign of star wars squadrons is a
solid showcase of set pieces that
conveys what's possible with the game's
engaging flight combat mechanics
juggling all the tasks required on your
cool starfighter while soaking in the
sights and sounds of star wars
has been a treat in the first eight
hours even if i'm left a bit wanting
so that's what i think about the star
wars squadron single player story
campaign
be sure to keep an eye on gamespot for
my full review in the coming days
thanks for watching
you